we will now go through an example that
brings together all of the concepts that
we have introduced we have a stick of
length L and we break that stick at some
random location which corresponds to a
random variable capital X and we assume
that this random variable is uniform
over the length of the stick so its PDF
has this particular shape and for the
PDF to integrate to one the height of
this PDF must be equal to one over L
then we take the piece of the stick that
we are left with which has length X and
we break it at a random location which
we call Y and we assume that this
location Y is uniformly distributed over
the length of the stick that we were
left with what does this assumption mean
it means that if the first break was at
some particular value little X then the
random variable Y has a conditional
distribution which is uniform over the
interval from zero to X so the
conditional PDF is uniform a conditional
PDF like any other PDF must integrate to
one so the height of this conditional
PDF is equal to one over x our x and y
independent no one way to see it is that
if you change little X the conditional
PDF of Y would have been something
different whereas if we have
independence all the conditional PDFs
have to be the same when you change the
value of little x another way to see it
is that if I tell you that X is 0.5 this
gives you lots of information about Y it
tells you that Y has to be less than or
equal to 0.5 so the value of the random
variable X gives you plenty of
information about the other random
variable and so we do not have
independence notice that in this example
instead of starting with a full
description of the random
variables in terms of a joint PDF we use
a marginal PDF and then a conditional
PDF to construct our model of course
with these two pieces of information we
can reconstruct the joint PDF using the
multiplication rule the marginal is 1
over L the conditional is 1 over X so
the joint is equal to 1 over L X but for
which values of x and y is this the
correct expression it is correct only
for those values that are possible so 0
has to be less than y less than X less
than L this is the range of values that
are possible in this particular
experiment and we can visualize those
values they are those that correspond to
this shaded triangle here x and y are
less than or equal to L and y has to be
less than or equal to X if you try to
visualize the joint PDF notice that
since it only depends on X not on Y if
you fix a value of x and you look at the
slice of the joint PDF the value of the
joint PDF is going to be a constant on
that slice on this slice it's going to
be another constant actually a bigger
one when that slice an even bigger
constant and actually this constant is
bigger and bigger and goes to infinity
and as we approach 0 of course the fact
that the slice is constant is just a
reflection of the fact that the
conditional PDF is constant over the
range of values that the random variable
can take let us now continue with some
calculations let us find the marginal
PDF of Y how do we do it since we have
in our hands the joint PDF we can find
the marginal by integrating the joint
and in our case the joint is equal to
one over L X and we integrate over all
X's now what is the range of the
integration if we fix a certain value of
y the joint PDF is actually 0 in this
region and in that region so we should
only integrate over X's that corresponds
to this interval
what is that interval it's the interval
that ends at L and because this is a
line slope 1 this value here is also y
so we integrate over an interval where X
ranges from Y to L in fact this is just
the range of X's that are possible for a
given value of y x must always be larger
than or equal to Y now the integral of 1
over X is a logarithm and using this
fact we can evaluate this integral and
it's 1 over L times the logarithm of L
over Y for what Y's is this a correct
expression well it makes sense only for
those Y's that are possible in this
experiment and that's the range from 0
to L when y is equal to L we have the
logarithm of 1 which is equal to 0 so
the value of the PDF is 0 here and as Y
decreases this ratio increases and goes
to infinity so the log of that also
blows up to infinity and we get a shape
of this form where the function that
we're dealing with goes to infinity as
we approach 0 is this a problem having a
PDF that blows up to infinity not really
as long as the area under this PDF is
equal to 1 it's still a legitimate PDF
and blowing up to infinity is not an
issue let us now calculate the expected
value of y one way of doing this is by
using
definition of the expectation it's the
integral of Y times the density of Y
which is one over L times the log of L
over Y and the range of the integration
has to be those values for which we have
a nonzero density so integrate from zero
twelve which are the possible values of
the random variable Y this is an
integral that's pretty messy one can
actually integrate it using integration
by parts but the calculation is a bit
tedious so let us look for an
alternative and more clever approach the
idea is to divide and conquer we're
going to use the total expectation
theorem where we're going to condition
on X the total expectation theorem tells
us that the expected value of y is the
integral over all possible values of the
random variable X which is from 0 to L
the density of X which is 1 over L times
the conditional expectation of Y given
that X is equal to some little X and we
integrate over all X's why is this
simpler when we conditioned on X taking
a specific value Y has a uniform
distribution between 0 and X and
therefore this conditional expectation
is the expectation of a uniform which is
1/2 the range of that uniform so we
obtain the integral from 0 12 1 over L
times x over 2 DX and finally that's an
integral that we can evaluate easily or
we can think even in a simpler way this
expression here is the density of X this
is X itself so the integral of this
times X gives us the expected value of X
and there's only a factor of 1/2 that's
less
out there so we obtain 1/2 the expected
value of X but now X itself is uniform
on an interval that has length L and
therefore the expected value of x is L
over 2 and so we get a final answer
which is 1/2 times L over 2 which is L
over 4 this answer makes intuitive sense
if we break a stick once the expected
value of what we're left with is half of
what we started with but if we break it
once more then we expect it on the
average to be cut by a factor again of
1/2 and so we expect to be left with a
stick that has length 1/4 of what we
started with so this example is a
particularly nice one because we used
all of the concepts that we have
introduced marginal pdfs joint PDFs
conditional PDFs and the relations
between them as well as expectations
calculations of expectations and
conditional expectations as well as the
total probability theorem